hi I'm Phoebe Robinson co-host of the
WIC podcast Twp Queens and here are some
of my favorite videos of all time
YouTube you know the first video is DMX
singing Rudolph the red-nosed reindeer
[Music]
this is pretty self-explanatory
DMX can't sing he barely seems to know
the lyrics and he grunts a lot so if you
don't laugh at this like you're the
problem the second one okay you guys I
love Oprah when I say I love Oprah if I
had like not waxed I would shave her
name into my pubes sorry yeah back in 96
when she had her TV show she was like
you know what I'm so rich I could do
whatever and she recorded her own theme
song to her show called run-on and she
made a music video
see what these will be and it's just her
like hopscotching with kids and her
wearing like a billowy white blouse like
she's freaking like royalty it is so
insane she can kind of sing okay like
she can't get above that level you know
I mean so it's like oops you're not
perfect that makes me feel good about
myself
[Music]
number three is this video that I love
so much because it makes me cry did I go
chuckle mostly I'm I like tracks ace
so there's just a little autistic kid
who's like big big big big big fan of
Coldplay who isn't I love them too he's
loved him for years and his death
finally got him tickets to go to the
concert and he starts crying and then
the dad starts crying and then I'm
crying and that I'm eating food to make
myself stop crying it's a really bad
cycle but it's worth it to feel all the
feels
[Music]
and finally my last video number four
when you look back in history you're
gonna be like where was I the day that I
saw Corey Feldman on The Today Show
doing some crazy-ass Michael Jackson
nonsense
he was pop-locking horribly he was
wearing like a hoody like he's on g-man
[Music]
it made no sense he had a black guy come
out and freaking New Balance sneakers
and like slacks rapping I'm like did you
get my Uncle Carl like what are you
doing this is horrible but it's
literally the best five minutes of your
life I'm Phoebe Robinson thanks for
watching I hope you like all these
videos and if you like them a lot tweet
at me dope Queen Pheebs and we can have
a conversation they'll go maybe like two
tweets and they don't get tired but the
first two tweets
I'll mail it where's the thing